the 2016 results are a springboard to
mass defections and the destruction of
at least one of the old parties it's
time for the Republican Party to fall
apart and go away or the Democratic
Party I don't really care which there
has arguably never been as much interest
in a libertarian National Convention as
there is this year in orlando in 2016
it's for a variety of reasons we're
going to get into them with libertarian
National Committee Chair Nicholas sore
work Michael asst thank you for joining
recent TV thanks for having that
basically since the end of the Indiana
primary the world woke up and said oh my
god we're going to have those two people
for six months we need to look for
something else have you seen a material
change in the Libertarian Party status
even in the last month absolutely
basically for the last three weeks I
haven't been off the phone reporters
from all the major outlets are covering
us and what people realize is that the
bill crystals of the world that never
Trump people they were just never
serious they never had any kind of
ground game they never had an actual
candidate they could pick and so when it
comes to November there will be three
parties that will have a candidate in
front of all Americans the two old ones
and then the Libertarian Party talk a
little bit about why that is so i
covered the ralph nader campaign in two
thousand he got two point seven percent
of the vote it was kind of significant
but the Green Party isn't on all 50
ballots why is that what did you guys do
that was different we're just better at
it frankly we didn't fall into the trap
that the Green Party fell into where
they got wrapped up in a personality
that makes it hard to sustain it's the
same thing that happened to the Perot
movement he got ninety percent in the
general but that never continued beyond
him once he was tired of politics it all
fizzled out the Libertarian Party has
taken a different approach we've worked
on building up state affiliates in all
50 states in the District of Columbia
and frankly we're just better at this
ballot access thing than all the other
parties talk about what it is required
to get to make that happen how much of
your energy is spent just making sure
that you develop this 50 state prize
over the last 45 years we've put
millions of dollars into breaking down
ballot access barriers into complying
with the petition requirements that the
two old parties put in place to try and
suppress the libertarian vote
this year and we're in a great ballot
access spot we're likely to spend about
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
just to give Americans a choice now what
have you seen in terms of numbers of
people visiting or memberships or other
things that would anecdotally or you
know put numbers on the support I've
seen recently memberships and revenue
are both skyrocketing we have been
inundated with people joining the party
memberships up about 12% just since the
cruise drop out daily memberships have
doubled or tripled revenue we've
quadrupled what we normally bring it in
a month and we're on track to continue
doing that as we go into the election
and it'll just get better once Sanders
gets boxed out by that corporate shell
so one of the bigger complaints that you
hear from people about the Libertarian
Party is that how come there isn't a
libertarian senator or how come you
don't have people in local office what's
your response to the response is this is
always an argument in the party do we do
we run top of the ticket to Iran local
races the answer is we can walk and chew
gum at the same time the National
Committee has a goal of having over a
thousand candidates up and down the
ballot nationwide in 2016 and there's a
coattail effect both directions
presidential candidates do better when
there are local candidates running and
vice versa so our strategy is to do both
what is the goal there's a lot of goals
and that's the beauty of it the obvious
goal is that I get invited to ignore a
shin parties for the libertarian
presidential candidate when he went or
she but below that there's also these
goals to send a clear signal to the two
old parties that were tired of them
controlling Our Lives we're tired of
them fighting over which one of them
gets to take my taxpayer money and give
it to their special interest friends it
doesn't matter which one the answer is
no we want neither of them so a large
vote percentage where we control the
balance of power actually lets us have
more control over the direction this
country goes over the positions that a
presidential candidate takes then the
two old parties together if you look at
how the Perot vote total affected how
President Clinton governed you can see
how you can drive policy from the bottom
and if you look at positions libertarian
party's taken since our founding in 1971
marriage equality and cannabis
legalization have been core to the party
from the beginning marriage equality is
the law of the land across
the country cannabis legalization is
having a ground swell of support and
neither of the old parties got involved
in that they didn't catch up to marriage
equality until after it was already a
fait accompli the question that I'm sure
you're offending constantly and I get as
well from mainstream media is like okay
who are you pulling from most these days
is that just like an alien question to
you at this point does it feel like that
the younger generation of libertarians
don't even think from the from the
standpoint of Democrat Republican
politics yeah it's a question I get a
lot historically our demographics we
pull about a third from old Republicans
a third from old Democrats and a third
from people who just weren't involved /
were identified as independent in this
latest election right now we're getting
a lot more members who are dissatisfied
with the Republican nominee but as soon
as the Democratic nominee is chosen and
the popular guy doesn't get it then
we're going to get a lot more members
from there so i think we'll maintain
that evenness but one of the things you
point out the largest bloc of voters in
this country are the people who don't
bother to vote and the next largest are
people who choose not to affiliate with
either the old parties and if you look
at partisan voter registration figures
since 2014 the Libertarian Party is the
only party that's growing in voter
registrations Democrats are declining
Republicans are declining Constitution
is declining greens are declining only
the libertarians are growing and so
we're seeing a lot more influx of people
who have never had a political home
before who are choosing to make the
Libertarian Party their first home walk
us through what five percent means five
percent means ballot access retention in
many states that have a vote test to see
whether or not a party can continue to
be on the ballot it means eligibility
for presidential matching funds which
then there would be a philosophical
argument in the party about whether or
not we should take federal money at all
it means legitimacy in the eyes of a lot
of voters who haven't quite gotten there
to be able to vote libertarian it says
that we're for real we're not going
anywhere you know the fact that we're
here after 45 years we're going to be on
the ballot in all 50 states on something
no other political party other than two
old ones is going to be able to do we
own our own national headquarters our
vote totals and our vote floors keep
arising across the country we're in it
for the long term
we're in it to win and it may take you
know two years four years 20 years but
we're not going away and the old parties
frankly are dying what in your mind is
the failure line this time if you don't
get X what will you consider to be a
failure of this presidential race I
think going backwards would be a failure
if we don't do better this time than we
did in 2012 I would consider that to be
a bad result in the presidential
campaign and if we had a bad result we
would dust ourselves off just like we
did after certain campaigns in the past
that people don't like to talk about
2004 so okay 04 08 wait you know we just
move forward the party is bigger than
any presidential candidate you know I
hope that we'd get a really good nominee
I hope we get a great vote total but the
party will continue after that five and
a half months of the presidential
campaign is done and we'll keep running
those people locally and we'll keep
exciting and energizing activists who
want a political party that represents
them they want a party for people who
just want to live their own life raise
their own kids run their own business
relax how they want to on the weekend
love who they want to love there are no
parties for that there are parties for
you know special interests and corporate
cronies and and just for bullying other
people there's two choices there but
there's only one choice if you want to
empower individuals and let them make
their own choices for their own lives
walk us through the ideal if everything
rolls right in 2016 what that looks like
scenario if all the IFS turn out well
for the LP this time and then we get
what what does that look like to you the
ideal is that we use this as a
springboard the 2016 results are a
springboard to mass defections and the
destruction of at least one of the old
parties basically the ideal is to follow
the line of the Whigs when they
basically fell apart and turned into the
Republican Party it's time for the
Republican Party to fall apart and go
away or the Democratic Party I don't
really care which but at least we would
get to a point where you basically have
a plurality system in this country we
would break the two-party system and
make it a three-party system so that
there are actual political options with
sorry thank you very much for reason TV
I'm Matt Welch